Da ist er wieder: Karl Marx in seiner
ganzen revolutionären Pracht –
die Ikone des Kommunismus in Bronze.
Und das Beste: Zum Geburtstag
gibt's die Statue gratis –
Chinas Geschenk an die Trierer.
Es ist ein Symbol für die
zukunftsträchtige Freundschaft
zwischen Deutschland und China!
Wenn das so einfach wäre: Die
rechtspopulistische AfD gibt Kontra,
wenn auch diesmal schweigend.
Ausgerechnet die Partei,
die sonst fremdenfeindliche Sprüche klopft,
pocht auf Menschenrechte.
Für die Opfer des Kommunismus erklärt
sie Karl Marx verantwortlich
und will ihn vom Sockel stoßen.
Drei Straßen weiter: das Gegenteil.
Sozialisten, Kommunisten, Marxisten
feiern ihr Idol und drohen: Die Revolution
steht unmittelbar bevor – mal wieder.
Ich sehe das natürlich so, dass die marxsche
Weltanschauung hochaktueller denn je ist.
Als am Marx-Denkmal die dazugehörigen
Flaggen auftauchen, da wird deutlich,
dass es noch immer ein
schwieriges Verhältnis ist
zwischen Marx und den Trierern.
Es wird ein Wallfahrtsort werden für
alte und neue Kommunisten.
Das hat heute schon begonnen
an dieser Stelle.
Unfug! Ich will keinen Faschismus,
weder von rechts noch von links.
Ja, ich auch nicht!
Na, Ihre AfD ist doch ganz nah dran!
Haben Sie dafür gestimmt, für diesen ...
Ist doch ganz nah dran!
Die Chinesen lässt der Krawall kalt,
sie sind ja zum Glück für
die Demonstranten hier
in Trier nicht zuständig.
Die Stadt empfängt die Delegation
wie bei einem Staatsbesuch.
Auch darüber wird in Trier gestritten:
Biedert man sich zu sehr an,
muss man nicht viel mehr
Distanz zeigen zu dem Land,
in dem Menschenrechte wenig zählen?
Wenn wir unsere deutschen Maßstäbe
anlegen und nur mit Staaten reden,
die die gleichen Maßstäbe erfüllen im
Sinne von Pressefreiheit und, und, und,
dann sind wir ziemlich alleine
auf der Welt.
Ein Kopf aus Marx-Zitaten – das deutsche
Präsent fordert viel vom chinesischen Gast.
Um das zu genießen, brauchen wir Leute,
die sich mit Marxismus auskennen.
Und die sind im heutigen China wohl
seltener anzutreffen als in Trier:
der Oberbürgermeister – ein gefragter
Mann im chinesischen Staatsfernsehen.
Er ist stolz auf den größten Sohn der Stadt.
Trier ist das neue Karl-Marx-Stadt?
Trier ist nicht das neue Karl-Marx-Stadt.
Trier ist 2000 Jahre alt,
die älteste Stadt Deutschlands. Aber
Karl Marx gehört zu Trier dazu.
Eine Karl-Marx-Straße gibt es hier schon
länger, allerdings etwas verschämt
in einer eher finsteren Ecke
am Rande Triers.
Jetzt bekennt man sich offensiv zum
Marx-Marketing: Die Andenken-Läden
machen Kasse mit allen möglichen
Souvenirs zum Jubiläum.
Ein schönes Beispiel ist unser
Null-Euro-Schein. Marx hat gesagt,
er würde das Geld am liebsten abschaffen,
weil er konnte ja auch selber
nicht besonders gut mit Geld umgehen.
Und insofern bezieht sich dieser
Null-Euro-Schein – ich sag mal,
in einer ironischen Weise – auch auf Marx
und auch auf Marx’ Geldtheorie.
Was Marx selbst nie geschafft hat:
Kapital schlagen aus dem „Kapital“
und manch anderen Devotionalien.
So viel Geschäftssinn verwirrt
dann selbst die chinesischen Gäste.
Unser Entwicklungsziel lautet: Bis 2035
eine grundlegende Modernisierung
des Kapital… des Sozialismus erreichen.
Oder doch umgekehrt?
Der neue Marx „Made in China“
wird wohl auch das verkraften
– nicht nur in Trier.